when you think about what makes a
university great it's really not a
homogeneous community it's a diverse
community that does care an awful lot
about underrepresented populations and
particularly in our STEM disciplines
women had been underrepresented and even
in the temper school we have seen
significant growth in terms of the yield
in women we've worked very hard at what
happens on campus when women come on any
of our our programs and so one of the
first things we did which I thought was
brilliant as we got our women students
to address our faculty in their regular
faculty meetings and talk through what
has made them feel inclusive and what
hasn't and using examples from the
professor's who are in their classroom
and so it was in a way really
identifying best practices and it
allowed faculty to understand how men
and women can potentially experience a
very different classroom it's really
great to see like so many girls just
like me like getting out wanting for
stealing their dreams and I love how
it's so equal this time and especially
means a lot since engineering is like
typically like not super not that many
women in that field and I traditionally
underrepresented so it's really awesome
to be in like my physics and math and
they intro classes and like there's so
many girls raising their hands to making
up just like me
they're certainly seeing Carnegie Mellon
perhaps differently than maybe some of
their predecessors I've got to say we
know we're pretty proud of the advances
that we're making and I think that it
makes a difference in the university
community I can't tell you how many
faculty have reiterated how important it
is to have women you know represented in
a way where the strengths of those
students come out the biggest change we
implemented was in the fall of 2015 we
introduced this new core education which
really aims to develop students as a you
know holistic manner as scholars
professionals global citizens and engage
citizens and as well as people with a
sense of wellness and balance so it's a
really holistic sense of Education as
opposed to just looking at the the
academic or scholarly side of of an
education when I came for admitted
students a
actually my first time on campus I got
to sit one-on-one with a college of
science student from Virginia after that
I actually through a family friend got
to talk to a woman named a pic shot at
all I sat down with her for about an
hour and a half and she is a biology
major and an English major and so she is
completely crossing the spectrums of
disciplines I saw myself in them and I
saw how they worked and I really saw
like my process is reflected in theirs
and I also saw them doing wildly
successful things and that made me
really hopeful that I could one day do
it too there's no better time to be an
undergraduate admission quite frankly
and and I think in no better place than
it currently Malin